[Aplausos]
qué bonita no tenía el pelo más largo
muy buenos días qué gusto estar aquí
fíjense que hace poquito fui a dar una
charla a la universidad y yo llegué a si
bien pomposamente anunciándome como
activista en la movilidad y nos faltó el
valor a que levantó la mano y dijo que
es una activista
oh my cut me puse a reflexionar en que
es una activista si yo nomás andaba en
bici que tengo que andar haciendo yo en
estos menesteres esto que traigo es la
convención sobre los derechos de las
personas con discapacidad
eso es una activista déjenme platicarles
brevemente como de qué va cómo es que
una gorda se sube a la bici y termina
como consejera de derechos humanos por
ejemplo ya no es por farolear pero pues
hay si algo se les ofrece
yo antes de que se hablara de activismo
ciclista o de movilidad yo ya andaba en
bici era como a principios del siglo 20
nació el 21 especial venció nada como a
principios de siglo
yo tranquilamente me iba a mi trabajo en
bici pasaba a dejar a mi criatura su
escuela lindo barato enriquecedor
divertido hasta que alguien no le gustó
y me dijo oye es que eres docente en
bachillerato porque estás dando ese
ejemplo
ok pues guarde la bici no más como 10
años
y asumí mi rol de docente saque el carro
pero a los años
hipertensión no pues dieta olvida lo
mejor me vuelvo a subir a la bici y
entonces fue una una renovación digamos
porque me acerqué a un colectivo para
que me asesoraran no me quería infartar
sola verdad en el camino y este y este
colectivo me arropó y así aprendí
digamos algunos detallitos ya no solo
andaba en bici al trabajo sino que me
incorporé a los paseos empecé a ayudar
me integré al colectivo luego por
curiosidad a la liga peatonal después me
fui a la red nacional de ciclismo urbano
y hoy estoy aquí y entonces yo todo esto
lo podría resumir si en tres patadas
para mí ser activista es estar dispuesta
a aprender dispuesta como sucede en las
bicicletas verdad caerme al levantarme
sacudirme y volver a pedalear
y no quedarme con eso porque si me quedo
con eso pues para qué sirve a la mejor a
mí me sirvió en un momento pero si me lo
quedo nada más me sirve a mí entonces
pues considero que eso es un activista
quien aprende y comparte sobre todo
porque casi todos los activistas y esto
es algo que he podido observar en los
últimos 34 años somos personas con mucha
suerte porque porque podemos ir a un
congreso porque podemos acceder a cierto
grado a cierto nivel de conocimiento y
de interacción con personas que saben
mucho
y realmente trabajamos para aquellos que
no pueden ser activistas como nosotros y
eso de repente te abre a un panorama de
mucha injusticia social
luego entonces permíteme tanto además
del libro también traigo un manual de
cómo ser un buen ciclista si alguien
quiere tengo más ejemplares el asunto es
que entonces se abre todo un panorama
porque ves injusticia social por todos
lados he aquí tres pequeños aprendizajes
que quiero compartir con ustedes el tema
de movilidad te lleva a pensar en la
seguridad social o sea en la seguridad
de la sociedad quiero decir no empiecen
a pensar en este inseguro no y qué tan
seguros andamos en la calle y la verdad
es que tienes quieres sentir la
adrenalina de un espejo por aquí a un
lado de tu oreja súbete a una crisis
circular por las calles de la paz pero
también habla de reestructurar este
tejido social que muchísima falta nos
está haciendo ejemplo un taquero un día
me detuvo así bien al armado donde
andaba tenía una semana de no verla me
tenía con pendiente y yo había ido un
curso y entonces no pase por su taquería
como todos los días y él estaba muy
alarmado dijo está ya la atropellaron
por ahí por ejemplo y te das cuenta
de que eres visible de otra forma cuando
manejas no puede decir si buenos días
buenos días cuando vas caminando cuando
vas en bici interactúas con la gente la
gente te ubica sobre todo o sea no
ubicar esto en una bici está muy
complicado verdad pero no nada más
fíjense bien no es nada más una cuestión
de seguridad de nuestras calles y de
hacer comunidad sino que también es un
asunto de justicia de justicia social
empodera el tema de movilidad cuando
hablamos de ciclistas cuando hablamos de
peatones en poder a los más vulnerables
porque ese es el tema reconocer que
tenemos privilegios y a partir de éstos
hacer algo lo que se te ocurre y lo para
lo que te alcance pero hacer algo por
los que tienen menos privilegios que tú
porque sabes para ellos quizá no son
privilegios y son derechos
de tal suerte que me ven haciendo un
montón de cosas fundé un pequeño
colectivo este se llama así ya saben
busquen nos damos like bien y desde ahí
andamos lo mismo defendiendo o
procurando que terminen una ciclovía
este renegando porque no son respetados
los derechos de la comunidad lésbico-gay
que no se queriendo que ya no construyan
más puentes anti peatonales porque son
excluyentes feos caros una serie de
etcéteras pero sobre todo dándonos
cuenta y compartiendo esta idea que para
mí ha sido muy poderosa no podemos
seguir permitiendo como sociedad que un
pequeño grupito de gente desde sus
omisiones o desde su corrupción permitan
que los derechos de otros sean
pisoteados no no no nos lo debemos
permitir y a veces es la corrupción y la
ignorancia quizá de algunos sobre todo
de los que toman decisiones que no se
ponen bien en la pila y también la
ignorancia y la apatía de otros que no
hacemos nada ni siquiera reclamar no se
valen las quejas en facebook esas no
sirven de nada les aclaro
entonces pues tratamos de difundir este
tema de los digamos de los derechos del
peatón pero también difundir la idea de
que es nuestra obligación y es nuestro
derecho defender por ejemplo nuestros
ecosistemas nuestras calles nuestras
habilidades la seguridad que debemos de
tener en las calles que tenemos que
salir salvo los que trabajan en casa y
dios los bendiga y que envidiar pero
casi todos los demás o vamos a la
escuela vamos al trabajo y no se vale
que ese camino cotidiano diario te
cueste la vida porque porque alguien
tiene mucha prisa pero sobre todo
entender que hay poderes mucho más
grandes que el que yo pueda tener
ahorita aquí igual que podamos tener
todos en bola y que amenazan cosas tan
básicas tan esenciales tan sagradas como
la vida como el ecosistema como el agua
no a la mina no podemos permitirlo no
nos podemos bueno si podríamos pero no
deberíamos porque eso nos puede costar
la vida pero que creen no soy la única
loca hay otros locos y nos conocemos y
nos unimos ay qué miedo y de repente me
encuentro formando una red de
organizaciones de movilidad de inclusión
y eso es muy bonito porque resulta que
ya no es la cristino ortuño loca que de
todo se dé todo reniega nadal en bonn a
nada le gusta no es que cuando decimos
no nos gusta no nos embona nos sirve es
porque atenta contra los derechos de
alguien
me explicó hideaki 2 epifanías bueno ya
les dije pero les quiero dejar muy
remarcadas 2 epifani es que a mí me ha
dejado además de muchos insultos y
muchos enojos y muchos berrinches esto
de la activismo en movilidad me ha
dejado estas 2 epifanías maravillosas
una
en el tema de la calle y es realmente un
tema de derechos humanos y hay que
defenderlo y la otra es como una
enfermedad te pica ya no se te quita
nunca no es como por des invitarlos pero
si se quieren hacer activistas es una
cosa que ya no se pueden quitar de
encima pero sí les quiero invitar a la
acción de esta manera les quiero invitar
no tiene crean pero así que por lo menos
lo pongan en duda si después de oírme en
estos minutos que por cierto les
agradezco su atención si después de aquí
cuando manejen los que manejan
y ya tienen un poquito más de cuidado o
no se desesperan con un peatón que cruce
la calle despacito no le quieren echar
el callo del carro o no le pitan quítate
vaca ya la hice si saliendo de aquí como
peatón no te resignas a tener que
bajarse de la banqueta porque alguien
estaciona su carro sobre la misma y
demás y te quejas y haces algo al
respecto qué chido porque ya sirvió de
algo lo que te viene a decir y sobre
todo y una última cosa que para mí es
muy importante que lo hagamos no porque
nos vayan a multar o no porque hoy la
cristina va a tomar una foto y la va a
subir al facebook porque si lo hago por
cierto aguas no vamos que les parece
vamos haciéndolo porque es lo correcto
respetar los derechos del otro y
empoderarnos y defender nuestros propios
derechos eso es algo pues la verdad que
nadie lo va a venir a hacer por nosotros
hay que echarle ganas e imaginación y
coco y una última cosa y esta reflexión
sin ser yo una feminista si se las
quiero dedicar sobre todo a las mujeres
que ya no se sientan tan jóvenes y a las
mujeres en general
cuando de repente porque muchas mujeres
me han dicho hay cómo le haces para
subirte a la bici pues así hago la pata
y no es tan complicado no no no pero
como no te da miedo andar en la calle
así pues si me da miedo pero me lo agua
el pedaleo y tengo que seguir pedaleando
porque si no me caigo peor aún hay
mujeres que me han dicho de mi edad y
más jóvenes hay es que a mí me gustaba
tanto andar en bici cuando era joven y
luego osea no te has muerto sabes
anímense no se queden con las ganas y
cuando de repente tengan miedo de hacer
algo o de intentar algo nuevo porque hay
que van a decir ay no ya no estoy en
edad ay qué pena acuérdense de esto que
están viendo acá si una mujer ya entrada
en años en kilos y en carnes puede
aprender cosas nuevas subirse a la bici
y andar queriendo cambiar el mundo que
no podría ser yo los espero gracias
[Aplausos]